one of the many things
you uh you have work on you're an expert
in
is black holes can you first say what
are black holes
and second how do we know that they
exist
right so black holes are the ultimate
prison
you know you can check in but you're
just
even light cannot escape from them so
there are
extreme structures of space and time
uh and there is this so-called
schwarzschild
uh radius or or the event horizon of a
black hole
once you enter into it with a spaceship
you would never be able to tweet back to
your friends
and tell them by the way i asked the
students in my class freshman seminar at
harvard they said
let me give you two possible journeys
that you can take i said
suppose aliens come to earth and
suggest that you would border spaceship
would you do it
um and the second is suppose you could
board a spaceship that will take you
into a black hole would you do it
so all of them said to the first
question
yes under one condition that i'll be
able
to maintain my social media contacts and
report back
share the experience with them i
couldn't but personally i have no
footprint on social media yeah which is
as a matter of principle yeah my wife
asked me when we got married
and i uh honored that and i told you
offline i need to get married
she's such a woman she truly is a
special agent well she
she was wise enough to recognize the
risk but um
it saves me time and it also keeps me
away from crowds
you know i don't have the uh
notion of what a lot of other people
think so i can think independently i
think exactly yeah exactly but
uh putting so i was surprised to hear
that for students
it's extremely important to share
experiences even if they go on a
spaceship with
aliens they still want to brag about it
rather than
look around and see what's going on this
is not an option when you go to the
black hole that's exactly the point
so for the black hole they said no
because they're obviously you can find
your death
after uh you get into it and you can
crash into singularity
you